merci laurent depuis le début de ce
conflit nous essayons de vous donner le
maximum de clés pour comprendre les
tenants et les aboutissants de cette
guerre en plein coeur de l'europe avec
jean michel carpentier nous revenons à
présent sur quelques grands points
d'histoire qui éclaire cette crise
unique depuis la deuxième guerre
mondiale
ils sont plus de 600 mille six cent
mille kosovars albanais chasser ces
derniers jours loin de chez eux pour un
total depuis 1991 de plus de deux
millions de personnes déplacées en
dehors du territoire rêvé par les
partisans d'une grande service car
depuis plus de 100 ans la serbie n'a
cessé de changer de frontières comme le
montrent ces différentes cartes en 1878
deux empires se partagent la région des
balkans et la serbie d'aujourd'hui que
l'on voit ici en pointillés est occupée
au nord par l' empire austro-hongrois et
au sud par les turcs de l'empiré ottoman
en 1885 apparaît la première serbie
moderne à cheval sur les deux empires et
qui parvient en 1913 à s'étendre au
kosovo lors des guerres balkaniques
juste avant la première guerre mondiale
en 1942 les nazis la réduisent pendant
la seconde guerre mondiale puis 145 elle
s'agrandit de nouveau à la libération et
trouve encore de nouvelles frontières en
1995 avec les accords de dayton
depuis la bataille du chant des mers
auprès de christine à entraide 189
chaque serbes considèrent le kosovo
comme le berceau de son peuple
cette victoire turque eux marquent le
début de l' empire ottoman apparaissent
alors au fil de l'histoire
les premiers déplacements de population
ça a commencé en fait en dix huitième
siècle avec la reconquête de de
certaines régions de croatie dalmatie
par les autrichiens par venise ça
continue au dix neuvième siècle avec
l'indépendance de la grèce de la serbie
et de leur agrandissement chaque fois
ils ont chassé les populations
musulmanes
ça a continué pendant les guerres
balkaniques
ça a continué pendant la première guerre
mondiale car à peine les deux empires
ont disparu que serbes croates slovènes
bosniaque bulgare albanais se déchirent
des centaines de milliers de personnes
sont chassées de chez elles et en 1918
le traité de versailles créé le premier
royaume de yougoslavie
mais les tensions nationalistes persiste
sur fond de montée du fascisme et
évidemment les tentatives d'épuration
ethnique menée par exemple par les
oustachis contre les serbes en croatie
en bosnie pendant la deuxième guerre
mondiale
cette fois ce sont les oustachis croates
alliés des nazis qui s'entraîne au serbe
sept cent mille victimes serbes mais
aussi des juifs et des tsiganes
disparaissent dans les camps de
concentration ou s'exile à la libération
la yougoslavie de tito étouffera les
vieilles rancunes pendant 35 ans
mais à sa mort en 1980 les haines
ethniques et religieuses ressurgissent
comme en 1981 avec des émeutes au kosovo
et dans la foulée l'arrivée au pouvoir
de slobodan milosevic prêt à tout pour
fonder la grande serbie mythique
on connaît la suite jamais encore on
avait eu un processus aussi radicale
aussi systématique et aussi rapide que
ce qu'on a maintenant nous sommes passé
malheureusement à l'ère moderne du
nettoyage ethnique autant de massacres
et de réfugiés autant de haine pour
l'avenir et d'esprit de revanche entre
partisans de la grande serbie et
combattant de la grande albanie
cette nouvelle guerre du kosovo n'est
sûrement pas la dernière
si l'on ne parvient pas un jour à
dessiner des frontières accepté de tous